i'm not a soldier
i fight for my family not the
crown the season we spent all this time
like getting it to this point we wanted
to build the tension between all the
different characters
everyone close to you always ends up
suffering
now it's your turn brother
everyone is constantly changing and
evolving
they manipulate each other so things
become really tense
there can only ever be one queen and she
is me
every character has just hurt each other
so deeply that it's hard to trust
alliances where we go he goes i still
don't trust him
marco is trying to save her people her
family and do the right thing whatever
lie you tell comes my lie as well
if the queen says it
it's not a lie
this season characters are extremely
complex
everyone has some kind of vendetta
against each other
when you left i was still a weaker one
that's no longer the case
as the season continues we see a tension
build between everyone
they're everything you still think
you're special we are special the cracks
that we're already starting to show
throughout season one just stop widening
the things we do for family
my own brother stands between us
and victory
[Applause]
[Music]
no matter the outcome i would lose
they protect his children that's a
driving force from baba
that's when when papa sees his brother
he wants to just oh
full attack
everything about baba nido's life was
just leading to this matchup
i don't want to kill you
don't worry
you're not going to
[Applause]
you